En el 2023 se han cumplido 20 años de la
invasión de Irak.
Posiblemente, estamos hablando de la guerra
que marcó la adolescencia de todas las personas
de entre 30 y 40 años que veis este canal.
Seguro que muchos de vosotros aún tenéis
en vuestra mente imágenes que ya forman parte
de la Historia.
Imágenes tan famosas como esta.
Ahora bien, seguro que muchos también recordáis
las grandes manifestaciones y protestas en
contra de la guerra.
Y esto es algo interesante.
Porque esta guerra se produjo prácticamente
al mismo tiempo que la Guerra de Afganistán.
Sin embargo, amigos, la intervención militar
en Afganistán tuvo mucha mejor prensa.
Todo el mundo entendió que era una respuesta
adecuada a los atentados del 11-S.
En cambio, la guerra de Irak fue muy polémica.
El No a la Guerra fue el lema de una serie
de protestas multitudinarias en contra de
la decisión del Gobierno de Estados Unidos
de invadir Irak.
Especial protagonismo tuvo el mundo del cine
en España, que convirtieron la Gala de los
premios Goya en un acto protesta contra el
apoyo del Gobierno de José María Aznar a
la guerra.
Pues bien, curiosamente, nadie duda 20 años
después de que la guerra de Afganistán fue
un fracaso total que ha terminado con los
talibanes de nuevo en el poder después de
una evacuación bastante bochornosa.
En cambio, en Irak, todavía hoy día permanecen
alrededor de 2.500 soldados estadounidenses.
Es más, todo indica que no hay ninguna prisa
para que se vayan.
(El primer ministro iraquí apoya la presencia
indefinida de tropas estadounidenses.
WSJ)
Vamos, que un soldado estadounidense no puede
entrar en Afganistán ni aunque quisiera mientras
al mismo tiempo en Irak son casi hasta bienvenidos.
Bueno, no del todo, pero ya me entendéis.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Por qué se produjo
la Guerra de Irak?
¿Hasta qué punto fue un fracaso?
¿Cómo es el Irak actual?
En VisualPolitik hoy vamos a dar respuesta
a todas estas preguntas, pero antes, vamos
a ver un poco de Historia.
Atentos.
(T1.
EL MALO DE LA PELÍCULA)
Hubo una época, allá por los años 90, en
el que la Unión Soviética ya daba menos
miedo que Expediente X y la amenaza china
parecía más bien el nombre de una prueba
de Humor Amarillo.
Así que durante muchos años Saddam Hussein
fue el icono del mal.
En South Park era más malo que el propio
demonio.
Era tan malo que ya en la guerra que enfrentó
a Irak con Irán en los 80, la Casa Blanca
terminó por apoyar al régimen de los ayatolás.
Quizás para garantizar que nadie ganara y
las dos partes perdieran.
(A mediados de los años 80 estalló el escándalo
Irán-Contra.
La administración del presidente Ronald Reagan
estaba vendiendo en secreto armas a Irán,
país sobre el que pesaba un embargo armamentístico
decretado por Estados Unidos.
Con el dinero obtenido, la Casa Blanca financiaba
a la Contra, un grupo armado que luchaba para
derrocar al gobierno nicaragüense surgido
de la Revolución Sandinista.
Ambas operaciones, la venta de armas a Irán
y la financiación de la Contra, estaban prohibidas
por el Senado estadounidense.)
El caso es que la paz entre Irak e Irán no
llegó hasta 1988 y, por supuesto, nadie ganó:
las fronteras continuaron en el mismo lugar
que estaban antes de la guerra.
Eso sí por el camino perdieron la vida casi
un millón de personas.
Y tras 8 años de destrucción, las economías
de ambos países también quedaron destrozadas.
Cuando acabo la guerra, Kuwait, que era una
petromonarquía aliada de Saddam Hussein,
empezó a reclamar a Irak el dinero que le
había prestado para combatir a los ayatolás.
Hablamos de ni más ni menos que 14.000 millones
de dólares.
Así que la relación entre ambos países
comenzó a torcerse hasta el punto de que
Irak acusó a Kuwait de robar su petróleo
mediante el uso de técnicas avanzadas en
campos fronterizos.
Era una acusación sin fundamento, pero el
régimen de Saddam estaba preparando el terreno
para invadir Kuwait, algo que hizo en agosto
de 1990, provocando un rechazo unánime de
la comunidad internacional.
(Durante 5 meses la diplomacia intentó que
Saddam Hussein retirara sus tropas de Kuwait.
El Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU aprobó
5 resoluciones en este sentido.
Finalmente, el 16 de enero de 1991, una coalición
internacional de 34 países encabezada por
Estados Unidos y bajo mandato de la ONU, inició
una campaña militar para obligar al ejército
invasor a replegarse de Kuwait, atendiendo
a la resolución 660 de la ONU, aprobada de
forma unánime.)
Así comenzó la Guerra del Golfo, la primera
de toda la Historia en ser televisada en directo.
La Operación Tormenta del Desierto duró
6 semanas y fue un gran éxito.
Vamos, lo fue tanto que Estados Unidos hubiera
podido derrocar fácilmente a Saddam Hussein.
El general Norman Schwarzkopf, al frente de
la operación militar, asegura que le pidió
al presidente Bush padre una semana más para
acabar con Saddam.
Pero la Casa Blanca no quiso.
En una entrevista para Frontline, de la cadena
PBS, Schwarkopf ofrece detalles de por qué
no derrocaron a Saddam en 1991.
Fijaos.
(“Me hubiera encantado haber ido a Bagdad
y capturar a Saddam Hussein, pero esta no
fue una decisión emocional, fue una decisión
estratégica, y estratégicamente fuimos lo
suficientemente inteligentes como para ganar
la guerra y ganar la paz.
(…) Si Saddam fuera reemplazado mañana,
probablemente sería reemplazado por alguien
que es tan malo o peor que él”.
General Norman Schwarzkopf.)
Posiblemente, los más jóvenes estaréis
pensando, vale, me queda claro que a finales
del siglo pasado Saddam Hussein era el malo
de la película.
Pero, ¿qué hizo para convertirse en semejante
villano?
Incluso muchos os preguntaréis: pero a ver
Fonseca, ¿si era tan malo por qué no lo
derrocaron en 1991?
Pues bien, su historia arrancó en los años
60, en una época de golpes de Estado en Irak,
donde la posición de Saddam Hussein mejora
tanto que pasa del exilio a la vicepresidencia
de la República gracias a su liderazgo en
el Partido Baaz Árabe Socialista.
(El socialismo árabe fue una corriente ideológica
muy popular a mediados del siglo XX.
Supone una mezcla de 3 elementos claves: socialismo,
con una economía centralizada dirigida por
el Estado, laicismo, ya que están en contra
de poner el liderazgo religioso por encima
del político, y militarismo, con un papel
destacado de las fuerzas armadas en la organización
del Estado.)
El socialismo árabe fue evolucionando.
Comenzó siendo panarabista, con el objetivo
de unir a todos los árabes en una sola patria
ya que consideraban las fronteras existentes
como artificiales.
Pero al final, los enfrentamientos entre los
dirigentes baazistas de los diferentes países
desembocó en la aparición de ramas nacionalistas
del Baaz.
Así Saddam Hussein pudo rechazar cualquier
injerencia y en 1979 se convirtió formalmente
en el presidente de Irak.
Gobernó con mano de hierro rodeándose de
una élite que como él eran suníes, una
minoría que apenas constituía una quinta
parte de la población iraquí.
Luego Saddam se dedicó a invertir el dinero
que generaba el petróleo en el ejército.
Lo convirtió en el cuarto ejército más
grande de todo el planeta, algo que no está
nada mal para un país que entonces apenas
tenía 18 millones de habitantes.
Y hasta aquí muchos estaréis pensando: bueno,
pues era un dictador como otro cualquiera.
Vale, es verdad, pero es que Saddam no es
que oprimiera a su pueblo.
Es que les llegaba a matar con armas químicas.
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado bien.
En los años 80 SaddaBVs países han calificado
como un genocidio la operación Anfal, que
se saldó con la destrucción de 4.500 poblaciones
y el asesinato de alrededor de 180.000 civiles.
Episodios como la masacre de Halabja, ciudad
que fue bombardeada con armas químicas provocando
5.000 muertos en solo una noche, forman parte
de la historia negra de la Humanidad.
Ahora bien, tampoco seamos ingenuos.
Probablemente, este no sea el motivo por el
que se actuó con tanta fuerza contra de la
invasión de Kuwait.
Otro buen motivo está en el zumo de dinosaurio.
Irak es un país rico del mundo árabe, productor
de importantes cantidades de petróleo y de
gas.
Y con Kuwait su poder hubiera sido excesivo.
Y, ojo, que hablamos de una época dónde
todavía no había llegado el fracking.
El petróleo de Oriente Medio era también
imprescindible para Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, al mismo tiempo y por ese mismo
motivo se necesitaba que Irak siguiera bombeando
crudo para mantener estables los precios en
los mercados internacionales.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Es posible que esto explique en buena medida
por qué Estados Unidos no quiso acabar con
el régimen de Saddam.
Sí, era un dictador terrible, pero tenía
el país controlado y necesitaba vender petróleo
para seguir financiado al ejército.
Así que entonces se puso en marcha el juego
del palo y la zanahoria: si te pasas de listo,
te damos un toque y amenazamos con invadirte;
si te comportas, te dejamos estar porque así
Irak permanece estable.
Sin embargo, esta política cambió en 2003.
¿Por qué?
Pues…
Atentos.
(T.2 NO A LA GUERRA)
Los atentados del 11-S dejaron en shock a
la gran superpotencia norteamericana.
Estados Unidos había sido atacado en su propio
territorio por Al-Qaeda y el presidente Bush
había emprendido una guerra contra el terror.
Esto condujo a la invasión de Afganistán,
donde el régimen talibán daba cobijo a Osama
Bin Laden.
El líde r de Al-Qaeda logró escabullirse
de las fuerzas estadounidenses.
Así que la Casa Blanca empezó a ver en todas
partes enemigos que pudieran echarle una mano.
Y claro, el historial de Saddam Hussein no
ayudaba.
Claro que el tiempo ha demostrado que los
nexos entre Al-Qaeda y Saddam Hussein eran
falsos.
Pero que ambos odiaran a Estados Unidos ya
era suficiente para la Administración Bush.
De este modo el Gobierno estadounidense logró
que el Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU aprobara
la resolución 1441, una resolución con la
que la comunidad internacional instaba a Irak
a colaborar con los inspectores de desarme.
Pero Washington quería más.
Presionaba para que se otorgara un ultimátum
a Saddam Hussein.
Sin embargo, amigos, este ultimátum no llegó
y en marzo de 2003 la Casa Blanca decidió
hacer la guerra por su cuenta.
Hasta el último momento, Bush trató de convencer
al mundo del peligro de no actuar.
Efectivamente, la razón oficial para invadir
Irak fue que Saddam Hussein tenía ocultas
las famosas armas de destrucción masiva.
Había dudas y una parte importante de la
comunidad internacional se oponía a la intervención.
Pero pese a ello, el Congreso de Estados Unidos
autorizó en octubre de 2002 a atacar Irak
si la diplomacia fracasaba.
De hecho, el presidente Bush contó con un
amplio apoyo de senadores del Partido Demócrata
como, por ejemplo, el propio Joseph Biden,
actual presidente de Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, a diferencia de la Guerra del
Golfo, esta vez no hubo una gran coalición
internacional para combatir a Saddam Hussein.
Tan solo Reino Unido envió un fuerte contingente
de tropas mientras que los Gobierno europeos
se dividían entre los que estaban en contra
de la guerra, como Francia y Alemania, y los
que apoyaban la intervención, como España,
Italia y gran parte de Europa del Este.
El caso es que, quizás, por esta división,
la invasión causó una gran polémica y se
produjeron protestas multitudinarias por todo
el mundo.
Nadie entendió por qué había que invadir
Irak y artistas e intelectuales lideraron
movimientos populares internacionales como
el No a la Guerra o el No blood for Oil.
Pero pese a todo, la invasión fue un gran
éxito a nivel militar.
El Ejército estadounidense conquistó Bagdad
en tan solo 3 semanas.
Y apenas 6 semanas después de que diera comienzo
la guerra, el presidente Bush anunció el
final de las grandes operaciones militares
en Irak.
Lo hizo bajo un gran cartel que ponía “Misión
cumplida”, algo que fue muy criticado con
el paso del tiempo a la vista de que aún
se estaba muy lejos de pacificar el país.
Además, en este discurso Bush se marcó un
nuevo objetivo: conseguir un Irak democrático.
Se había conquistado Bagdad y se había derribado
la gran estatua de Saddam Hussein.
Se había aplastado al ejército iraquí.
Sin embargo, todavía quedaban muchos cabos
sueltos.
El más importante es que no se había apresado
al dictador.
Se había tomado su palacio, pero no había
ni rastro de él, ni de su dinero, ni de las
armas de destrucción masiva.
Tuvo que pasar medio año para que finalmente
se encontrara a Saddam escondido en un agujero
en el suelo.
Fue entregado a las nuevas autoridades iraquíes
y el juicio contra él acabó de la única
manera posible: Condenado a morir en la horca.
Y amigos, Saddam Hussein se mostró desafiante
hasta el final.
Así reaccionó a su sentencia.
En principio, la Guerra de Irak fue un gran
éxito para Estados Unidos: había reafirmado
su poder como la gran superpotencia militar
del momento y tenían motivos de sobra para
darse por satisfechos.
Pero claro, este no era más que el comienzo
de ese objetivo de hacer un Irak democrático.
Ahora es cuando viene el gran dilema.
¿Realmente se puede construir un Estado?
Lo vemos.
T3(¿ES POSIBLE IMPONER LA DEMOCRACIA?)
Mucha gente considera que Bush era un iluso
porque se pensaba que podía imponer la democracia
en un país por la vía militar.
Porque claro, como Saddam Hussein había sometido
a Irak con una dictadura criminal, la Casa
Blawnca se debió imaginar que en Irak todos
estaban esperando que llegaran los marines,
les salvaran del tirano y entonces todos tan
contentos.
El problema es que al día siguiente te tienes
que poner a construir un Estado que entre
unas cosas y otras está destruido.
Sin embargo amigos, vamos a decirlo claramente.
Esto de llegar a un país devastado y poner
en marcha una democracia es algo que ya ha
funcionado en Alemania y Japón.
Incluso en Corea del Sur.
De la Segunda Guerra Mundial salieron años
después la democracia alemana y japonesa.
Estados Unidos jugó un papel decisivo para
que así fuera.
Y de la Guerra de Corea salió Corea del Sur.
Cierto es que durante las primeras décadas
pasó por un sistema autoritario y una dictadura
militar.
Pero con el apoyo estadounidense, terminó
convirtiéndose en una democracia próspera.
Sin embargo, volviendo a Irak y a Afganistán,
todo parece más complicado.
En 2021 Estados Unidos puso fin a la Guerra
de Afganistán y ya visteis todos el desastre.
La democracia afgana sucumbió ante los talibanes.
En Iraq las cosas han sido diferentes.
Obama anunció la retirada total de las tropas
estadounidenses en 2011.
Pero los enemigos de la joven democracia iraquí
eran de tal calado que exigieron el regreso
del Tío Sam apenas 3 años después:
(Estados Unidos despliega nueva fuerza en
Irak para impulsar la lucha contra el Estado
Islámico.
Reuters)
Estados Unidos cometió muchos errores en
Irak.
Apostó por líderes que promovían las divisiones
sectarias y étnicas como forma de ganar apoyos.
Políticos que gobernaban para los suyos antes
que servir a los intereses nacionales.
Así era muy difícil construir un nuevo Estado
para todos los iraquíes.
Otro error fue disolver el ejército.
Esta decisión favoreció que las antiguas
tropas de Saddam nutrieran una insurgencia
atomizada en múltiples grupos armados decididos
a luchar contra el invasor.
Una insurgencia tan difícil de combatir como
de derrotar.
Ahora bien, la realidad es que en Irak sí
que se han producido cambios de calado.
Desde 2005 han celebrado elecciones libres.
Y dentro de la debilidad de las jóvenes instituciones
iraquíes, se puede decir que 20 años después
de Saddam Hussein hay una democracia funcionando
en Irak, donde el poder se transfiere de forma
relativamente pacífica y cada vez hay mayor
seguridad en las calles.
Incluso la producción de petróleo nos da
una buena pista de cómo ha ido evolucionando
un Irak que actualmente es el segundo mayor
productor de la OPEP con más de 4 millones
de barriles diarios.
Ahora bien, tampoco vamos a decir que ya todo
va genial en Irak y que Bagdad se ha convertido
en las Vegas.
Un problema de la democracia iraquí, que
también se produjo en Afganistán, es la
corrupción nachovidaliana:
de los saqueos en las calles se ha pasado
a saquear el erario público de una forma
que ríete tú del AK-47 bañado en oro de
Saddam.
Pero de los problemas del Irak actual hablaremos
en un próximo vídeo.
La reflexión final es que George Bush lo
hizo: Irak se transformó en una democracia.
Eso sí, a un precio prohibitivo.
Muchas vidas se quedaron porw el camino.
También tuvo que poner mucho money.
Porque Estados Unidos se gastó un auténtico
pastizal en esta guerra: 800.000 millones
de dólares según las estimaciones más prudentes
y billones de dólares según otras más generosas.
Y todo para que, en contra de lo que muchos
pensaban, en Bagdad termine gobernando lo
más alejado a lo que podríamos considerar
como un títere de Washington
(En una democracia gobiernan las mayorías
y en Irak la mayoría de la población es
chiita.
Por tanto, hoy día están gobernando en Irak
las facciones chiitas que más apoyo han recibido
de Irán, la gran potencia del Islam chiita
y hoy día uno de los mayores archienemigos
de Washington.
El mayor error de la invasión fue no tener
un plan para el futuro de Irak después de
la guerra.)
Irak es una democracia, sí, pero ahora es
una democracia bajo la influencia de Irán,
sin duda el gran triunfador en la región
de la guerra de Irak.
La mayor demostración de que la estrategia
estadounidense no ha sido precisamente brillante.
Pero, ahora el turno es para ti.
20 años después de la guerra, ¿Consideras
que fue un acierto invadir Irak?
Volviendo a las palabras de Bush: ¿valió
la pena el esfuerzo para transformar Irak
en una democracia?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a Visualpolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.